how did you actually go about maximizing
that track record because I think a lot
of people don't first thing I did was
exactly what you just said so you know
it was to get a really well worded email
together you know showcasing what I've
done for competitors and essentially say
look I can do this here's an example
could we speak about how I can help you
guys whether that's now in the future
and I think something really big to
focus on is if you don't know that
company are bidding or have just won a
massive project it can be about in the
future it's going back to that this is a
long game you might not do a placement
with that company for six 12 months but
if you've got ahead and you've had that
conversation so they know where you are
when they need you that's great and
that's a win and you need to be able to
see that but then maybe try and follow
that up with a BT call but it's so much
warmer because you've already put your
case across them